Ми супроводжуємо співробітників Українського Червоного Хреста до Куп'янська
- для евакуації мирних жителів.
Нині цей район - одне з найнебезпечніших місць поряд із лінією фронту.
Це як адреналін вже.
Ти постійно їздиш, їздиш і не звертаєш на це уваги.
Ризик заради того, щоб зберегти людям життя…
Ризикуєш, але при цьому робиш корисну справу.
Ігор Яковлєв, Український Червоний Хрест
Люди ж не вині у тому, що відбувається.
Влада України оголосила обов'язкову евакуацію
для мешканців Куп'янська та прилеглих районів.
Росія стверджує, що захопила позиції у цьому регіоні.
Обстріли та руйнування стали тут частиною повсякденного життя.
Перша зупинка Ігоря сьогодні
- село на околиці міста.
Анна та її троє маленьких дітей готові до від'їзду.
Вона мешкала тут із родичами чоловіка. Його вдома немає.
Свекруха Анни, Олена, відмовляється їхати.
Вона та ще двоє її синів вирішили залишитися.
Я не хочу їхати.
А на кого я кину будинок?
У мене двоє дітей ще з собою.
А куди я поїду? Мені нікуди їхати.
Олена написала на воротах "люди та діти",
сподіваючись, що це стане хоч якимось захистом, якщо росіяни повернуться.
Івану приблизно стільки ж, скільки триває повномасштабне вторгнення Росії до України.
Значну частину його життя родина провела в підвалі,
ховаючись від обстрілів та російських військових.
Коли військові напивалися, у них були дуже гучні сварки,
доходило до бійок. Вони й стріляли один в одного.
Це було на наших очах.
Зараз були прильоти, будинок наш пошкоджений.
Дітям щось треба бачити, крім війни, окупації.
У них і так залишиться травма на все життя після того, що вони бачили.
Анна та її діти залишають небезпечну зону.
Але багато хто не наважується.
Близько 2000 осіб підписали відмову від евакуації і те, що вони усвідомлюють всю небезпеку свого рішення.
Багато хто в Куп'янську зустрічає нас вороже.
Інші розповідають, чому вони вирішили залишитись.
Якщо ми виїдемо з Куп'янська, навіть якщо мій будинок не розбомблять,
залишаться лише чотири стіни.
У нас так багато крадіжок - обчистять усю квартиру, все винесуть!
І я у 60 років залишуся ні з чим.
А куди мені виїжджати?
Мені 68 років. Кому я потрібна?
Буду я в Куп'янську, уб'ють - так уб'ють.
А що робити, куди поїду?
То я хоч вдома. У мене хоч щось є.
Місто Куп'янськ географічно знаходиться ближче до російського кордону, ніж до Харкова.
На початку вторгнення мер міста здався.
І російські військові окупували Куп'янськ на шість місяців.
Волонтери підозрюють, що деякі з тих, хто відмовляється їхати,
залишаються в надії, що Росія знову займе місто.
Ми називаємо їх "ждуни". Є таке слово…
Ігор Клименко, Український Червоний Хрест
На жаль, у цих районах на кордоні з Російською Федерацією
- країною-агресором та окупантом - такі люди присутні.
Чесно кажучи, всі, хто хотів і мав змогу, вони виїхали після звільнення.
Тому що сидіти цілий рік і слухати канонаду (вибухів)
- тут навіть найздоровіша людина стане хворою.
На цьому рекламному щиті на в'їзді до міста написано:
"Куп'янськ - це Україна".
З іншого боку щита: "Маєш інформацію про зрадників України?"
Слідчий розповів нам, що з 285 осіб у регіоні, проти яких ведеться розслідування щодо співпраці з Росією,
100 перебувають у Куп'янську.
Дехто навіть підозрюється в активній роботі проти ЗСУ.
Колабораційна діяльність стоїть для нас поруч із воєнними злочинами.
Є справи, коли ми приходимо в домівку до людини,
яка, може, публічно висловлювала в соціальних мережах інформацію проросійську,
а потім виявляється, що ця людина наводить ракети, є агентом ФСБ…
Анна з дітьми приїхала до центру прийому переселенців у Харкові
- за 100 км від Куп'янська.
Дітям дають іграшки, доки вона реєструється.
Сім'я отримує місця у гуртожитку -
вони можуть залишитися тут, доки Анна не вирішить, що робити далі.
Страшно, коли твоя дитина каже:
ми бачили там збитий танк.
В нас були військові, які були вбиті, просто лежали на дорозі.
І це діти бачили. Я не хочу, щоб вони далі бачили це.
Я хочу показати їм, що є набагато краще життя, ніж те, що ми бачили.
Я хочу їм показати набагато більше, ніж бачила я.
Хочу, щоб вони жили та мали все.